you're saying that these people are not
angels
if they get a discretion sooner or later
some of them are going to abuse it
[Music]
uh in our constitution reader we read
the progressives
john dewey's argument is it's a new
world
really different and as the world
changes he goes on to argue it changes
how we think
john dewey says those principles in the
declaration of independence
he says those fit for a pioneer agrarian
society
people thought like that right back then
and so everything's changed now the old
idea was
we're human we're capable of really
great things
as the federalist and we're capable of
really bad things
says the federalists and so we need to
arrange the government
so that there's a bias in favor of the
good things we can do
and government should be limited just
strong enough to protect us
from one another and don't give it
absolute power because
men are not angels true enough and they
have to have government
but angels do not govern men that's one
world
and another world is wow look how much
more we can do
by using these techniques let's do it
let's get going here right let's solve
these problems
let's get these checks and balances
out of the way let's stop this kind of
government that's offset against itself
so it's always
hampered and always a problem
right that's the argument and if you
just look at the power
of modern science look at the incredible
things it can achieve
doesn't that argument have great force
but you tell me what's wrong with the
argument i don't know that i'll be able
to fully develop this but it seems like
the last couple days we've really
established that
the true genius of the constitution was
separating
the sovereignty from the power and
keeping those two things separate so
they can check one another and keep an
eye on one another
it seems as you move towards this
bureaucratic structure that we're
talking about
you create like other tyrants you create
health problems or economic problems as
tyrants so in order to combat that you
have to like
they're arguing to recombine that
sovereignty and the power and put them
in the same hands to combat that
but then we forget that fundamental
principle in the declaration of
independence like all men are created
equal
and when we yoke the sovereignty and
power again
then we challenge that very thing that
all men have created equal
you mean you're nodding what are you
going to say well
we're talking about how whether or not
it the
principles of the constitution still
apply in a radically
different world but even if it were not
an agrarian society anymore
we're still a society of humans
and human nature doesn't change uh
we'd still suffer from the same ills and
make the same mistakes
so you're you're both saying in
different ways your argument is like
madison's argument you're saying that
these people
are not angels right right
and so if they get a discretion
sooner or later some of them are going
to abuse it you're saying that doesn't
change and you're saying
that's nature the excellence of the
human being
is nature and the fallings of the human
being
are nature and nature doesn't change
because
remember we defined this term nature
right and this term nature governs it
starts with babies it starts with seeds
but then it includes this fallenness of
human beings right this
capable of greatness capable of evil
both and that arrangement of government
and if you set out to overcome that then
here's the final question
if you can design your society any way
you want to
what standard will you use
to design it
what can give you any guidance i can
tell you what happened in nazi germany
right because
they just go right down this road and
what it means is
the guide that remains after everything
else has been eliminated
is strength only power can arbitrate
now what that means then i argue
is that these problems that come up in
society sure enough
one of the reasons we have the
government is to help solve these
problems
but if we think about it we understand
that yeah of course we need to make
things better in society we need to
treat people as well as we can treat
them
but also we have to be a little
suspicious of concentrating power
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and
invite you to explore all of hillsdale
college's online courses
they are free and for everyone who loves
to learn